okay let's look at the question
normalize this relational database into
four tables
how many is announced to the break and
ponder four including the employers they
will indicate all necessary
relationships public keys phone kids all
right so let's give this a go shall we
to start with I need to think about if
there are four tables what should the
tables be okay now what is a table let's
get back to the question the table is a
set of data here we go
they're all related to a single kind of
object or entity right so for instance
she has a loads table right she's called
this her lone stem because she says this
all relates to every learn that I've got
and you've got to know what's being
loaned who it's being loaned to when and
so on
okay in the same way if you go further
up a little bit you've got an employee
table right the table refers to an
object an entity a kind of thing in my
system employee and it tells me all the
stuff about the employee okay so let's
think about what are the objects or
items that exist in this system which we
could possibly make tables about now we
just need to okay we've got here we've
got employees what else could we make
tables about
okay yeah what would dine adduct give me
an example yeah okay items right so the
actual stuff stock takes care of is
laptops blah blah blah the actual things
being loaned okay good one two three
what else go back to the table sorry I
said yeah Department good now before I
write that down the reason why we would
say Department is because you look at
this table see this is the table which
we said do you see how the parts
correspond to each other pie a puppy
look at this table it's full of
redundant data
the reason it's full of redundant it's
really three tables kind of mashed into
one so this is the table that I'm going
to break apart and you've got a
redundant table that's the one that you
divide up okay
so I think we said I'm Department right
good is there anything else this is
that's four that's four is there
anything else
that's that's what I mean I there this
is for but should it be those four is my
question is it anything else that we
could make a table at all because this
is your first of all we thought of but
that the first ones you think I'm not
necessarily right now I know it was a
while but some of you should be telling
me a fifth one because it's what you
included in your diagram right
supervisors just like employees
supervisors are an object in the system
right and they're different from
employees right they're they're they're
sort of like on a level off right so we
know different things about them okay I
think you can probably stop there right
for there's five different objects
entities things that we could make
tables about so now I have to choose now
it might not be fine it could have been
15 right it depends on the kind of
question here there's not too many
options now is there's not a it's for a
good reason actually the first of you
did not think of supervisors okay
because out of these five I have to pick
four if I had to kick one out right it
would have to be one of these why do I
pick out those tables why is it one of
these that I think he got whi kind of
kick out these ever think you minute
okay let's get this you said two things
which sort of it the same thing I want
is a better way to say you said these
ones are all unique right so you can't
get rid of them because if you if you
remove them do you remove information
which you need in the system that's why
we're saying a better way to say it is
which set secondly these two tables here
are linked they're not just linked in
any way though what kind of relationship
do they have I just talked about
it's one-to-one right right
so really to talk about Supervisors is
to talk about departments right and to
talk about the parameters talk about the
supplies right this they're almost
interchangeable with no way they're not
quiet I'm going to suggest that the
better option out of these two is the
permits okay as I go through and create
the schema you have to think about why
that's the case
okay but I think that's probably the
better way to go